today we have Archimedes cattle problem
it was for a time probably the most
famous unsolved problem in math but now
no one has really ever heard of it but
it's a great story and I'm gonna tell it
to you Brady
maybe do we need to know who Archimedes
is yeah I think everyone in my
communities is like the most best
brilliant most brilliant of the ancient
mathematicians anyway this problem was
not known about until in 1773 at the
German intellectual he was a playwright
his famous intellectual got hold Ephraim
Lessing who at that time was the
librarian at Vulcan brutal which was the
Great North European library and
discovered a manuscript written in Greek
that no one had ever seen or picked up
all commentators commented about before
in this manuscript it said it was a
letter from Archimedes to Eratosthenes
who was his contemporary who was
actually at the Library of Alexandria
and it was a poem rift of twenty-two
rhyming couplets in Greek which said
this problem and I'm gonna my ancient
Greek isn't very good so I'm going to
transcribe the problem into the language
of today so the sun-god we're quite
nicely do a graphic of the Sun God had a
herd of cattle as I called the cattle
problems Sun God Yahweh you're wearing
your the Sun God I had a herd of cattle
and Archimedes from Syracuse see look
who's there in Sicily so the Sun God had
cattle and the cattle was all on the
Isle island of Sicily there are Bulls
and there are cows and they come in
different colors and this is how we
describe them the white Bulls 1/2 plus
1/3 of the black balls plus
fear levels the black balls 1/4 plus 1/5
of the dapple Bulls now my first comment
here is that this is an absolutely
terrible problem it is so boring it's
incredibly dull and you're gonna have to
speed it up but actually do carry on
because we
do get to why is actually really quite
fascinating
white bulls plus black bulls equals
square number and the dappled bulls plus
yellow Bulls equals a triangular number
and we have it so just to point out a
few things here that might be
interesting we've got bulls male calves
female we have only got unit fractions a
square number so that's a number that's
a square of another number so 1 4 9 16
25 et cetera a triangular number you
must have done many things like triangle
numbers but they are the ones that you
make triangles off so that's one and
then 3 and then 6 and then 10 basically
when you doing dots together that makes
a triangle and herd is
cows and bulls together both genders so
you have this I'm looking at it and I
get the call of dizzying effect that
this is the world's most horrible
simultaneous equation question what we
would do is that we would write it all
out you know called white bulls X black
Bulls why DAPA Bulls something else with
their non equations in however many
unknowns and we would start to work it
out
so what happened back to the story when
Lessing in 1773 found it he wasn't
mathematician and he went to his local
mathematician and said can you solve
this and it's true what you do is let's
go because the first section is really
straightforward this is something that
we could probably do many people really
could probably do you would get an
answer of it's just over 50 million
cattle the herd has about 50 million
which means on Sicily cuz I'm the Sun
King and I want to know how makes my
herd you've got one in cattle one piece
of cattle one animal for every about 500
square meters ok but this is a problem
written as a poem and in this kind of
commentary on the problem as we go and
it says don't get smoked and say that it
says even if you've got this far
thou cannot be regarded
of high-skill so there's some idea the
person that setting this puzzle is kind
of taunting you let's then try and
include the white bulls what's the black
Bulls is a square number this is
something that was also solved shortly
after it was discovered and now the
solution is 51 trillion so that number
in the hood is 51 trillion in other
words if you've tried to put all these
cattle on the Isle of Sicily Sicily is
completely covered in cattle you can't
see one square sentence will get a
millimeter of Sicily and the cattle are
stacked dozens if not hundreds of meters
high so it's this massive mound of
groaning mooing cattle now on to the
ninth line because now is where things
get really difficult in fact if you
include the line papal bulls plus yellow
bulls is a triangular number this is now
beyond the realms of 18th century
mathematics no one can solve it and it
becomes a celebrated problem it gets
around is the Archimedes problem we're
so close so close to solving it but no
one can do it the beginning of the 19th
century Gauss was the great german
mathematician the best management of his
age he's rumored that he has a proof but
no one ever sees it and it's only a
hundred years after the puzzle was first
discovered that the first person kind of
gets the answer and this is August Antho
a German and other German mathematician
and he doesn't get the full answer he
just realizes that the answer begins
with the digits seven six six and
continues for another two hundred and
six thousand five hundred and forty two
digits okay so how big is this number
this number in terms of the hood I'm the
Sun King on Sicily
you're gonna start layering Sicily put
the bottom layer of cattle dappled
yellow whatever start building them up
you're gonna go you're gonna go out the
atmosphere you're gonna then go beyond
the moon you're actually going to go
beyond the solar system out the galaxy
and go to the end
the universe and just only just
beginning it's going to blast through
the end of the universe
in fact this number is so big that if
every cattle was an atom they were not
enough atoms in the universe as we know
it it is such an enormous bonkers
number beyond all comprehension okay so
why would we ever want to know this
number well some people did so a couple
of years after three friends in America
decided they wanted to tackle this
problem and they spent four years on
this problem they only got another forty
four digits imagine that so this is
something that people wanted to know it
was this kind of kind of crazy
Archimedes number it was only in 1965
with the advent of Sukup supercomputers
that the full number was actually drawn
in printed on its entirety and it took
about seven hours and stretched to 42
sheets of a4 so what can we say about
the authorship of this problem lots of
people have said how do you know it
Archimedes well we don't know all we
have is the problem and it's state that
is remarkably easy to Eratosthenes some
academics some researchers think yeah
who knows it probably isn't but a lot of
them do and one reason why it might
because we know that Archimedes is
really really interested in massive
numbers in fact in the sand record
though one of his most famous kind of
treatises he invents a whole system of
numbers to try and describe try and
count the number of grains of sand there
are in the universe so we already know
he's in this area and maybe this problem
wasn't something to be solved but just a
demonstration kind of of the awesomeness
of mathematics to show that with nine
very simple statements statements using
nothing complicated you can actually
create a problem that describes a number
Italy beyond comprehension and that is
going to take 2,000 years to solve I
mean surely that's some kind of genius
if you wish to please the Sun God well
why not check out his latest book so you
think you've got problems it's by Alex
bellos it's full of puzzles and teasers
like the one we just discussed
it's the latest of Alex's mathematical
books and I'll include some links in the
video description along with more of our
videos here on numberphile that we've
made with Alex over the years thanks for
watching
[Music]